with almost 500 sessions at next 2018
it's understandable that you can get to
them all so if you didn't see hybrid and
open services with GCP envoy and sto
then stay tuned because here's the
rewind one of the challenges with making
modern cloud native applications is the
amount of strain that I can put on your
DevOps teams this is why we need strong
tools to do monitoring discovery fault
tolerance and observability for micro
service deployments no matter where they
run in this session we brought together
folks from Google cloud and lyft to
share what we've done together in this
space first let's talk about sto an open
source service mesh that makes it easy
to create a network of deployed services
with load balancing service to service
authentication monitoring and more
without any changes in service code this
is especially useful when transitioning
from monolithic applications to a
distributed micro service architecture a
few miles down the road from Google
ride-sharing company lyft was facing
similar challenges with their move to
cloud native as they built micro
services in multiple languages it became
much harder to create a common proxy to
support each language so they developed
envoy an open source distributed proxy
for large service mesh architectures
giving devops eventually consistent
service discovery and observability even
for micro services written in different
languages envoy used very similar api's
to internal Google api's so it became a
natural fit to build it into sto SDO is
comprised of a data plane and a control
plane envoy provides the data plane with
a set of intelligent proxies to control
all network communication between micro
services while the control plane manages
the proxies to route traffic and enforce
policies this now makes it possible to
make a service available to a single
Google kubernetes cluster and across
multiple clusters so with SEO & envoy we
get load balancing across micro services
in the same region but we still need the
ability to balance between regions as
well thankfully traffic director is here
to help
it's a GCP managed service that uses
open api to integrate with sto and
envoys service proxy
to give you global load-balancing
four-year back ends this is really
awesome because you can now expand
services and spill over across regions
it gives you centralized health checking
meaning each proxy doesn't need to check
one another lastly it enables traffic
driven auto scaling for your
containerized backends traffic moved
from one micro service in one region to
the next service in a different region
acting like a global load balancer but
for your own internal services now your
developers can continue to focus on
business logic without a PhD in
provisioning curious to hear more of the
discussion between lift and Google cloud
check out the full talk and hear more
from our panel with the link in the
description below and don't forget to
subscribe to the cloud YouTube channel
for more great next rewind content
thanks for watching
you
[Music]